[Aplausos]
[Música]
la alianza entre eeuu y los países
europeos no vive su mejor momento
donald trump ha llegado como un vendaval
y ha puesto a la pareja al borde de la
separación lo hemos visto con el acuerdo
de parís may the planets gay y también
con la posición de trump hacia la otan
la organización militar más poderosa de
todos los tiempos en maine prsc y no he
preguntado ni una vez cuánto ha costado
esta nueva sede de la otan me he negado
a hacerlo
precisamente hoy vamos a fijarnos en
esta organización que está pasando con
la otan porque donald trump a la crítica
tanto cuál es su importancia y su futuro
atentos a este vídeo pero antes de nada
tomemos un poco de perspectiva
[Música]
la otra una mirada atrás
al poco de terminar la segunda guerra
mundial la organización del tratado del
atlántico norte la otan se puso en
marcha
concretamente nació en 1949 con una
misión y un objetivo muy claros contener
frenar y en su caso vencer militarmente
a la unión soviética acababa de empezar
amigos la guerra fría y la tensión en el
ambiente era enorme se acababa de vivir
el bloqueo de berlín y el partido
comunista checo había tomado
completamente el control con un golpe de
estado en ese momento amigos de visual
político nadie descartaba ningún
escenario ni siquiera el de la guerra y
ojo pensemos en el contexto histórico el
mundo acababa de vivir la segunda guerra
mundial europa estaba destruida y la
desconfianza y el odio entre los
diferentes bandos ideológicos era
prácticamente total la verdad pensar en
una guerra a nadie le podía resultar en
aquellas circunstancias extraño pues
bien ese es el contexto bajo el que se
funda la otan integrada en un primer
momento por eeuu canadá
y 10 países europeos -francia reino
unido italia bélgica holanda luxemburgo
dinamarca noruega islandia y portugal
pocos años después además se uniría a la
república federal alemana es decir la
alemania occidental pues bien el
planteamiento esencial de la alianza su
espíritu pasa por unir fuerzas si un
país miembro es atacado se considera que
todos los demás países miembros también
son atacados algo así como el lema de
los mosqueteros de alejandro dumas uno
para todos y todos para un proyecto será
nuestra divisa claro que con muchos
matices y letra pequeña luego lo veremos
[Música]
la otan tras el fin de la guerra fría
sin embargo en 1991 todo cambio la caída
de la unión soviética dejó a la otan sin
una misión clara al fin y al cabo si el
enemigo desaparece qué sentido tiene la
alianza esa es una pregunta que muchos
hicieron en aquel entonces y que aún
muchas personas hoy día se hacen pero
esperad un momento porque contra todo
pronóstico es a partir de ese momento de
la desaparición de la unión soviética
cuando más actividad comienza a tener
esta organización de hecho la primera
intervención militar de la otan se
produjo en los 90 durante la guerra de
bosnia y desde entonces sus operaciones
han sido relativamente frecuentes
serbia kosovo afganistán libia el
control del báltico las operaciones
contra la piratería en el océano índico
y recientemente el apoyo a la lucha
contra el isis también ha sido en este
periodo amigos cuando más países nuevos
se han sumado al club desde que se
pusiera en marcha la otan la
incorporación de nuevos países ha sido
casi continua pero desde el fin de la
guerra fría desde 1991
se aceleró bastante
[Música]
si en el 49 eran 12 países hoy ya son 28
sus integrantes muchos de ellos por
cierto países del antiguo pacto de
varsovia que era algo así como la otan
liderada por la unión soviética algo que
la verdad no le ha sentado nada bien a
la rusia de vladimir putin
de hecho la guerra de 2008 entre rusia y
georgia se debió en gran medida porque
este país del cáucaso quería integrarse
en la otan algo parecido ha ocurrido en
ucrania y ojo tras la reciente crisis en
ucrania y el choque con vladimir putin
la otan parece haber pisado el
acelerador en 2015 realizó por ejemplo
las mayores maniobras militares en años
se movilizaron a más de 36 mil soldados
de 30 países diferentes también se ha
puesto en marcha en 2016 una fuerza de
acción inmediata compuesta por unos
5.000 soldados capaces de desplegarse
muy rápidamente en prácticamente
cualquier lugar la llamada punta de
lanza de la otan aglutina a unos 5.000
soldados que forman parte de una fuerza
de acción rápida más amplia compuesta
por 40.000 para garantizar y coordinar
despliegue la alianza ha creado desde
septiembre de 2014 ocho cuarteles de
apoyo todos en países de antigua
influencia soviética y en 2017 sin ir
más lejos y eeuu cumpliendo con una
misión de la otan está realizando el
mayor despliegue de tropas en europa
desde la guerra fría
eeuu planea un despliegue militar en el
este europeo inédito desde 1989
hablamos amigos de más de 4000 soldados
y cientos de tanques y vehículos
blindados que hoy ya están desplegados
en europa del este con una misión que
recuerda mucho a la etapa inicial de la
otan disuadir a rusia de cualquier
tentación expansionista sin embargo a
pesar de toda esa actividad hay
bastantes dudas sobre el papel de la
otan y sobre todo eeuu no está
precisamente muy conforme con el
compromiso de sus socios europeos
el enfado de eeuu como os decía antes la
garantía de defensa mutua si un país
miembro de la otan es atacado no es tan
clara como parece fijaos lo que dice el
artículo 5 del tratado de la otan que es
el que regula esta situación las partes
convienen en que un ataque armado contra
una o contra varias de ellas se
considerará como un ataque dirigido
contra todas ellas y en consecuencia
acuerdan visitará está que se produce
cada una de ellas asistirá a la parte o
partes atacadas adoptando las medidas
que juzguen necesarias incluso el empleo
de la fuerza armada incluso el empleo de
la fuerza armada ahí está es decir en
caso de que un país miembro sufra un
ataque no se obliga al resto a darle
inmediatamente apoyo militar por eso
todos los presidentes de eeuu desde
harry truman han aprovechado su primera
asistencia a una reunión de la otan para
hacer una interpretación del artículo y
comprometerse en militarmente
[Música]
sin embargo donald trump no lo ha hecho
se esperaba que lo hiciese en la
inauguración de un monumento a las
víctimas del 11-s en bruselas donde el
pasado 25 de mayo de 2017 asistió a su
primera reunión de la otan los países
europeos de hecho se lo habían pedido y
la casa blanca dijo que lo haría pero
trump al final no realizó ningún
compromiso bien hay analistas a los que
esto les parece muy importante y lo
presentan como uno de los mayores
errores diplomáticos de los últimos años
otros analistas no le dan tanta
importancia pero lo cierto es que en
europa ha sentado muy mal sobre todo
porque hasta el momento el único país
que ha invocado el artículo 5 ha sido
precisamente eeuu lo hizo tras el 11-s y
por supuesto recibió el apoyo inmediato
de todos los miembros de la otan
el caso es que trampa no quiso brindar
su apoyo lejos de ello aprovechó su
discurso para recriminar la supuesta
falta de compromisos de sus aliados
europeos
y criticar a los europeos mientras se
inaugura un monumento para recordar a
los 888 europeos 158 canadienses y 2 mil
396 soldados estadounidenses caídos en
afganistán no parecía fácil pero trump
lo hizo pero ojo este enfado no es sólo
de trap también obama lo compartía así
que la pregunta es y por qué en eeuu
están tan enfadados con la otan pues
básicamente porque afirman que los
miembros europeos de esta alianza no
están comprometidos y no gastan lo
suficiente en principio como regla los
países miembros de la otan tienen el
compromiso de gastar en defensa al menos
el 2% de su pib sin embargo sólo unos
pocos países cumplen que este criterio
reino unido polonia estonia grecia y por
supuesto eeuu el resto están bastante
lejos fijaos en lo que ha dicho james
mattis el secretario de defensa donald
trump a los países europeos los
estadounidenses no pueden preocuparse
más por las
de sus hijos que ustedes ahora bien
esperando un momento quiere decir esto
que los países europeos no gastan en
defensa para nada de hecho si sumamos
los presupuestos militares de todos los
países europeos miembros de la otan
veremos que cada año gastan más de
260.000 millones de dólares es decir que
si fuesen un país serían el segundo con
más gasto militar sólo tras eeuu vamos
que si hablamos en dinero contante y
sonante no parece que el problema esté
en que el nivel de gasto sea reducido o
al menos no parece que las amenazas de
hoy exijan o justifiquen un nivel de
gasto tan extraordinario sobre todo si
tenemos en cuenta el nuevo escenario de
seguridad y cuáles son los retos a los
que se enfrenta la otan porque amigos ya
no vivimos en los tiempos de la unión
soviética
[Música]
una obsesión de eeuu
digámoslo claro el mundo ha cambiado y
los retos hoy no son obviamente los
mismos que había en 1960 por ejemplo hoy
los grandes riesgos no se concentran en
la posibilidad de una gran guerra la
destrucción mutua asegurada la
globalización y el comercio han reducido
mucho ese riesgo hoy las grandes
amenazas las encontramos en el
terrorismo la piratería las ciberguerras
ojo muy importante y también en el
riesgo de proliferación de armas de
destrucción masiva tenemos que combatir
estos riesgos desde luego que sí pero es
algo amigos que no se consigue con más
tanques y más bombarderos luego también
tenemos que tener en cuenta que hoy nos
enfrentamos a una nueva forma de hacer
la guerra la conocida como guerra
híbrida donde los combates no son tan
explícitos como lo eran antes o como
salen en las películas
hoy las guerras modernas pasan cada vez
más por apoyar guerrillas y grupos
desestabilizadores presiones políticas
sanciones económicas
injerencia en los procesos electorales
acciones de inteligencia varias
fijaos en la estrategia de putin en
rusia algo de lo que por cierto ya os
hemos hablado en otros vídeos aquí el
visual político eso sí todo esto no
quiere decir que los miembros europeos
de la otan estén haciendo las cosas bien
por un lado la organización la otan
tiene establecido otro requisito además
del 2% del pib en gasto militar que es
dedicar el 20% del presupuesto a
inversión en equipamiento esto tiene más
sentido y aquí la mayoría de los países
europeos que gastan mucho dinero en
gastos fijos y en ejércitos con más
soldados de los necesarios tampoco
llegan por otro los países europeos
están poco integrados y manejan sistemas
de armas muy diferentes lo que claro
incrementa los costes de producción
mantenimiento y despliegue fijaos lo que
ocurre con los tanques por ejemplo eeuu
opera fundamentalmente un tipo de tanque
el abrahams mientras que los países
europeos operan hasta 19 modelos
diferentes de tanques imaginaos que caos
supone todo esto a la hora de realizar
un despliegue conjunto por ejemplo en un
país remoto en afganistán ni siquiera
pueden compartir en muchos casos líneas
de zoom
de repuestos y lo mismo ocurre con los
aviones la flota etcétera el caso amigos
es que tal vez la pregunta final sea
debe la otan jugar un papel importante
personalmente creo que sí que puede
jugar ese papel pero eso sí siempre y
cuando logre adaptarse a los tiempos y
cambiar su enfoque mi impresión personal
es que hoy tenemos que gastar mejor y
compartir recursos no gastar más aunque
esto lo siento pueda decepcionar a
muchos contratistas militares bueno y
ahora turno para ti puedes dejarnos tu
opinión en esta encuesta cuál quieres
que debe ser el futuro de la otan
defiende es que los países europeos con
un plan con las exigencias de eeuu ocre
es por el contrario que la otan tiene
que enfocarse a tareas menos
relacionadas con la guerra convencional
o crees que debe disolverse déjanos
también tu opinión en los comentarios y
ya sabes si el vídeo te ha resultado
interesante dale a like por cierto si
quieres saber quién es el mayor aliado
de eeuu y porqué donald trump ha puesto
en riesgo esa amistad no te pierdas este
vídeo un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]